[Music]
and
now we can begin so please join me in
welcoming larry fenn
hello hello good afternoon everyone
so i'll get right to it um i'll just say
a little brief bit about myself
i'm going to talk about journalism at
the associated press we use
r at least on the data team pretty much
to do
every part of our workflow we really
couldn't do it without r and r studio
and the libraries that exist for r
a brief brief high level summary the ap
is a not-for-profit cooperative new
news agency i'm a data journalist on the
data team
and so typical ap coverage
includes but is not limited to um
breaking news
so that is like non-negotiable that's
part of our blood that's kind of
you know when photographers run out to
grab a camera we as nerdy as it sounds
go looking for data go looking for the
story in the data you know it's a train
crash we look up
level crossing data stuff like that we
also cover investigative reporting so
that's sort of your
long-form deep dives into complex or
large data sets
something else about the scope of what
we do it's pretty much every level you
can imagine geographically
local municipal issues all the way up to
international
another big thing and i think this is in
common with a lot of
journalism news agencies not just the ap
but there's collaboration both
inside with domain domain experts who
are not necessarily so tech savvy or
data savvy but also collaboration
outside
people who again with wide variety of
backgrounds and
levels of expertise and it's it's very
important to try to synthesize these
viewpoints together
and finally what is it that we produce
at the ap we produce
pretty much everything you can imagine
from data text copy
graphics broadcast graphics social
interactive experiences like the fancy
ones you see on the web you know we
tried to do that too
so that's just a high level overview of
what it is that we do um
here's sort of what i'll just try to
cover just you know i'm leaving a lot of
stuff out because there is
a whole lot out of scope on on how
journalism works but
when it comes to data analysis let's
start so first we'll talk about how we
load in the data so there's a couple of
cool
really remarkable tools that r makes
available to us
first is dbplayer i don't know if people
are familiar with this one this is a
really great
really great library so um in particular
when you have data sets that are
extremely large so this was the arcos
pharmaceutical database i believe it's
it's some hundreds of millions of rows
it's something that you couldn't
even with a laptop like this one you
really couldn't work with it feasibly so
we have it hosted
and then you can see here there's a sort
of connection to it and just to
this is not necessarily like a tutorial
session but um the cool thing about
it is once you run this code you get
this connection and the way the
connection behaves with dbplier
is it it behaves basically like a data
frame but you'll see here
it says database and so the idea is
you're still able to use all those verbs
you're used to from the tidy verse but
you're hitting some sql database
somewhere on the somewhere in the world
really useful incredibly useful for us
another one is google forms and google
sheets so
this is often what we need to do when we
collect data
for a story because the data doesn't
exist you know
it's it's kind of awe-inspiring that you
know i don't we don't have to
pay for mechanical turk we can just sit
down and distribute work between
ourselves and and
sort of digest it all and so the
workflow there the way it looks i'm just
going to show it off a bit
we're doing the story about nfl injuries
and you know
it's out there that data is out there
but we wanted to make sure we were
counting exactly what it is that we
wanted to count and you know
drawing the lines we want to draw so we
came up with our own little survey that
we could then
hand out to reporters and then we could
all put it together like a sort of
human-powered mapreduce you turn that
crank and you get this great
data sheet at the end and then you plug
into it using google sheets for
so that looks like this and if you've
used google sheets for it's
pretty straightforward there's an oauth
step but you just do read sheet and then
you get the data right away ready to go
so that's another thing we do um last is
httr for apis so that's both including
ones that exist in the world like the
bls the labor statistics api
the census api but also um we have
homebrewed um
again databases and you know data admin
tools
one that i'll call out here is we sort
of looking at mass killings and we have
this whole
system that sort of we rolled our own
and use httr to get
the authentication token and to get the
data files
to get the relevant data off of the mass
killings database that we rolled
the use case here of course is you know
we often collaborate with other
organizations and so building
you know it seems like overkill but
building a standalone data admin tool
actually does save a lot of headaches
with collaborating with other large
organizations
the next thing is template graphics this
is something that
we are doing and we want to do more of
and
you know it's an endless struggle to
make better and better but
so the convenient thing for us is
there's an existing newsroom style guide
right we're not the first people to
to do graphs right um but that means
it's really easy for us
for me you know for us to kind of
develop um
using ggplot um a theme a theme package
we just follow very prescriptively what
the style guide is
and so this is actually available on the
associated press github if you want to
kind of ape
the graphical style github.com
associatedpress
ap theme you may not have this
proprietary font
my apologies you'll have to substitute
for some other font
but the cool thing is this also
facilitates conversation between
us and the other sort of graphics
able people in the newsroom because you
know we can say all right does this work
you know is this the style of graphic we
want to make does this
comport with our style guidelines and
that conversation with ggplot that
prototyping was so quick that
you know working it out and once we have
that theme in hand you can just
you know come up with graphics basically
as often as you have the idea for them
the other thing is we had to make sure
it fit into the existing publishing
workflows so we have a lot of artists
they use
illustrator they use vector graphics and
so it was really handy in the r
universe that you can just export these
graphics like vector graphics
really just perfect perfect as far as
plugging into how things already work
so last next we'll talk about reporting
the findings so
our markdown has come up already in some
of these case study um presentations and
it's you know it's pretty much the same
story here
people are in a hurry no matter who
we're trying to tell you know internally
externally
no one has time to read stuff so our
mark down is a crucial tool to help
condense what would otherwise be this
sort of long detailed rambling notebook
into a very condensed concise thing
the other advantage we used to roll our
own things before our markdown and
our notebooks came around we'd make
these web pages we make these graphics
it was a nightmare trying to make it
work for people who are trying to browse
these things on their you know at home
on an ipad
or something terrible but with our
markdown you know
it's just a set of really handy existing
sort of templates and tools that we can
plug into
so let me just show off kind of the one
just an example one so the nfl injuries
ended up being you know turned into
something simple like this so that we
can
hand to whoever is new joining the
project like hey here's we're gonna
catch you up like this is what we've
already got this is what we're studying
you know and this is where we're gonna
go with the story so really handy
dt that data table that you see at the
top here
great we love it uh there's the filters
you can also style it we don't really
do it that often but you can sort of
selectively highlight like oh make all
the ones that are above a certain size
bold
it's really quite handy and then leaflet
for maps
you know oftentimes i think a map is not
really the right tool for the job but
no doubt it can be a very useful tool in
data exploration when you first get a
data set to at least see
what is going on inside your data set so
that's where we're using our markdown
pretty heavily and it's
again we've made our own um our markdown
template and it's it's also on
the associated press github if you want
to just steal it
um so i'll just sort of wrap up i think
there's future directions so things are
not perfect we're still working on it
one big one you might not have noticed
here is interactive so static graphics
seems to be in hand interactive graphics
not so much
we've explored ggi rf plotly
you know bokeh you know some sort of
gg plot to d3 conversion there's kind of
still
you know we're missing that kind of key
piece there that kind of fits
and part of this is maybe what we need
out of it not necessarily like
i'm not claiming that there's no good
our interactive web graphic workflow
that's not true
but for our particular case it's been
sort of still a question of finding the
right tool for the job there
um automation got to have that buzz word
but the two big ones we're talking about
one is recurring data so some stories
they keep happening right spring housing
uh you know labor statistics that stuff
is recurring it's from an api you know
we can get better and better at closing
that loop and making it so that
you know when the data comes in there's
a minor there's a human involved
somewhere to make sure that the data is
you know correct but then
other than that all the other work has
already been done and we package it up
the other big one yeah this touches on
that is we want to make sort of a data
validation thing again not to remove
the human element from the whole story
because it's impossible to come up with
some sort of
magic script that'll catch all the
errors in your data but just
simple stuff like how many different
types of white space characters are
going on in this data file
um does this data file do day month year
or month year day
or month day year you know catching
those kinds of problems before they
become a real issue
sort of um i know that there are
certain like people have made some
efforts in this space and we're still
working on
trying to either contribute or latch
onto an existing solution there
working with python i know boo but there
are other people in the organization who
who work with python they make graphics
they do all these other reports in them
and
thanks to packages like reticulate you
know we haven't done it yet but
it hopefully is not far off that we can
bridge that gap within our organization
as well and that's that'll be a pretty
outstanding moment when we get there and
then lastly
the ap does this very particular thing
where we hand out data to
member papers and news orgs to then
localize stories for themselves
and you know we believe that r could be
a really
we could automate a lot more of that
also using you know r to script and to
control it we don't think we need
anything more than r to achieve that
goal
um with that that's just uh that's it
yeah that's a summary any questions
thank you again larry um yeah a few
questions come through so the first one
is how do you export plots as vector
graphics
oh yeah so um
you if you have svg light and you do
need to
um get installed with that so that's
like a system
dependency but when you're doing like a
gg plot
so yeah here i have this all in this ap
themes
script you see here when you call the gg
save function if you just make the file
name end with svg
it does it now that is to say though
there is one caveat
the graphic artists don't really like
the svgs that
are really svg light spits out and so
that's one thing we are also looking
into trying to improve
basically there's it's subpar it doesn't
quite line up with the way they like the
their project files to look but just
make the file name end with svg and
follow the error messages if it doesn't
work
great all right next question
when your team hires are they looking
for journalism experience how
important are writing skills versus data
analysis skills
oh that's that's tricky because
i was hired because of my background in
this but there are definitely
the team's core is about writing more
than anything else
i think if we were looking up you know
if we were thinking about
you know what is more in demand there's
still this question of
news judgment because
to pull back the veil we don't do a lot
of
you know bayesian analysis or neural
network modeling we really don't
um you know we would love to but the
reality is you know stories have to be
comprehensible to everyone and so that
kind of ties
behind our back the degree to which we
can really use advanced statistics and
mathematical knowledge
all right next question um how do you
get involved in doing
data analysis for journalism
so i think one on-ramp that has been
kind of cool
is there's a lot of state level in
particular open data communities
these are people who get together and
maybe it's something as simple as
election results or maybe it's something
more complicated like lead
testing results if you look on github
there are surprising amount of
sort of state open data communities that
are all about
you know in their state doing data
projects off of that and i think if you
you know if someone wanted to pursue an
interesting story
you know that might be the easiest way
to at least get started
i don't know how you could make money
with it but you could certainly start
investigating things at the state level
by reaching out to people folks who you
know work in open data
um stuff like k-12 education public
health that stuff is all
like those data sets are all out there
um waiting you know waiting for people
to find stories in them
cool thank you um how about uh
how can you convince your management of
allocating time and resources to
developing
work like this in r that may be costly
up front
that's a tricky one yeah we uh at least
in the
history of when i started um it often
times was a matter of building
good partnerships within the company so
you're not going to be able to get this
project off the ground but at least from
the journalism perspective
you know if there was already a strong
investigative project that you could
identify had a strong
data angle um that is sort of the
on-ramp there because then you can
tangibly show like how much better the
story is with the data angle
you know your mileage may vary in
different organizations
um final couple questions i think from
the same person so i'm just going to ask
them together
if other media rely on associated press
for breaking news
for breaking stories any future for them
also drawing
on ap's code example for quick
visualization to be rebranded also just
curious are you
paging through your presentation notes
in a reporter's notebook
uh yeah i do have a reporter's notebook
absolutely you got me dead to rights you
got me that's right
um for the code yeah we wanted to expand
um that as well so we are already doing
data distributions and we
are partnered with this organization
data.world and they have a sort of
web-based sql browser and we give them
sql code
out of the gate that they can use but we
definitely you know we believe
strongly that like you know
reproducibility and
you know distributing the code and
making it out there at least for members
hopefully eventually also for the public
as well so they can just
you know grab the public data grab the
code we used see the same exact things
we saw in the story
that's definitely a future goal for us
right now
yeah unfortunately it's sort of limited
to whoever is interested
we can't like kick down people's doors
and force them to use r
i know that's yeah
a few more coming in can you explain a
little more about how you do data
validation
right so oftentimes so what we're hoping
to do with the automated one is to catch
really simple things like
um oftentimes for example if
you're working with someone you're
requesting data from them and
they don't have the best data skills
they maybe did something in excel and it
truncated the data file at 1.2 million
or whatever the xl problem right picking
up that that happened that's something
that we
are hoping we can sort of build into
some scripting solution
more generally though how do we know
that the data is right that is a long
and tricky question and that is where we
intersect with traditional journalism
because
you know oftentimes like i'll look at
k-12 um
data and you know you'll just see
something
you'll you'll do the usual data analysis
and see the outlier and be like that's
extreme that's an extreme outlier what's
the next step you pick up the phone and
you call the superintendent and be like
well according to this survey data you
put this number in and then usually the
superintendent be like oh that's not
right or you know
it's it's a soft process unfortunately i
can't give you a cookbook for it but you
just have to be constantly critical
and for a lot of the stories where it's
really meaningful and worth it
we will just you know ultimately make
sure that
you know let's say we're reporting on on
shootings we'll go over every
you know that one of the thousand five
hundred shootings were that are in our
story to make sure we got it right
you know follow up with the police
department or something it takes a lot
of time and
you know but that's it's worth it
um do you have any sort of peer review
for your data analyses
so uh within the organization we
definitely make sure
you know we have these principles that i
think we've helpfully stolen from other
communities of you know second set of
eyes making sure that nothing hits the
wire without
you know multiple people's input on it
more broadly though when it comes to
stories
you know we we don't go as far as
handing the story pre-written to the
people that it involves
but um many times you know for example
for me
you know i if i'm doing something about
the bureau of labor statistics i'll make
sure to check in with the bls economist
who prepared that data
set and ask him is this a valid use of
your data i'm trying to write this story
this is exactly how i've set it up i'm
looking at these numbers and this you
know i'm trying to put it into this
analysis
and just asking the economist that
prepared that data you know up front
is this a valid use of the data and if
he says you know no you've got it all
wrong
it's seasonally adjusted you fool then
you know
yeah all right i think we have time for
one or two more
um what is your favorite data-driven
story that
you've worked on uh with the ap and why
ooh um okay there was one that was
really
hard but really rewarding we talked
about it was about k-12
education demographics um it involved
you know
this big big question which is charter
schools and
you know segregation by race and
ethnicity and while you know
obviously controversial topic one thing
that i really wanted to make sure we
could get across one thing that i
needed to make sure was in that story
and in that data analysis was to break
the traditional approach of saying
white non-white because i thought that
that was yeah it makes the analysis
easier because you've reduced it to a
binary sort of consideration but that's
absolutely not in my opinion the right
way to look at it
so it took a lot of time but coming up
with sort of new metrics that
captured the the multi-dimensional
nature of
race and ethnicity making sure we're
using metrics that
you know like you know we kind of picked
and stole the best ones from other
fields of research but like
you know how do people study housing
segregation how do people study you know
sort of
distributions of noise and information
theory what is the right way to
represent
similarity in a way that's deeper than
just saying white versus non-white
because so much of this country is not
just
a question of white versus non-white so
we're about out of time thank you again
larry fenn
you